[Music]
mowgli legend of the jungle has finally
hit netflix and whilst the film is
getting mixed reviews that doesn't mean
that it should be ignored the movie
features an all-star cast and sets of an
ending that adds a lot to the law of the
work by rudyard kipling throughout this
video I'll be breaking down everything
that you need to know about the movie as
well as its ending there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you're yet to see it
and I highly suggest that you turn off
now but for everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I roon it so you don't
have to after Mowgli breaks the laws of
the jungle and is banished from it he
begins to bond with his own people after
stumbling into a village Mowgli is
captured freed and then forms a
friendship with a hunter named Lockwood
Mowgli seems happy and even rejects the
call of his wolf brother who is
desperate to see him return and defeat
Shere Khan the tiger that murdered
Mowgli's family but when he discovers
Lockwood's trophy room which contains
the remains of Mowgli's friend he takes
an elephant tusk and returns to the
jungle to rally together the troops to
finally take Shere Khan down
Mowgli gains allegiance with the
elephants and they agree that once Shere
Khan is killed you will help them to get
revenge on the hunter who took the tusks
Mowgli tries to gain the wolves as
allies but they refused due to the laws
of the jungle and Mowgli heads out
without their help in the final battle
Mowgli defeats Shere Khan with the help
of the elephants and by using his wits
he lures the tiger up a tree and stabs
him in the stomach
this causes the villagers to come out
and see what the commotion is and when
they arrive with lockwood in tow who
takes potshots at the tiger
Mowgli points out that this is the
killer that took the elephants tusks and
the elephants charge him meanwhile Shere
Khan attempts to pouncer Mowgli to
finally kill him but the Wolves
intervene and save his life a kala who
was always anniversary of Mowgli
sacrifices himself to save the boy and
manages to deal Shere Khan a fatal wound
in the process
Mowgli follows him into the jungle where
he's finally able to kill his nemesis
once and for all Mowgli decides to
return to the jungle instead of humanity
where he can oversee the jungle as the
wolf pack's new leader to me Mowgli
witnessed the ugly side of humanity
firsthand where killing was dumped the
sport and knows who did it were lauded
as heroes even though they were often
evil but he did not align himself with
the laws of the jungle implicitly he was
still able to find justice within them
whereas the sight of humanity that he
witnessed had very little the voiceover
by car at the end highlights this and
states that there was peace in the
jungle for as long as Mowgli watched
over it to me this hammers home that he
did indeed live out the rest of his days
performing his duties as a protector due
to his ability to interact with both
animals and humans one would imagine
that he was able to sustain both
societies and stop hunters from ravaging
the land and animal life that lived
there
both Lockwood and Shere Khan upset the
balance of the jungle and civilization
by going where they did not belong and
Mowgli could be seen as someone who
keeps these barriers up in order to
protect life on both sides
Mowgli struggles with knowing whether he
is fully a man or wolf and by the film's
ending he is decided that he is both to
me this symbolizes that the village and
jungle will be able to coexist alongside
one another in peace much in the same
way that Mowgli has found peace within
himself to let both sides of his persona
exists as one so what your thoughts on
Mowgli The Legend of the jungle did you
like the movie and what did you take
from its ending comment below and let me
know and if you enjoyed this video then
please like it and check out my
breakdown of this week's other big movie
bumble bee which will be linked at the
end this is a channel for people who are
mad into movies so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]